talk to me about your def jam era
because as a fan it was extremely
frustrating yeah um because i had always
i guess when you ended up at def jam i
was like oh now this full it's always
going down right we and we have the
hip-hop
what
um
and i just felt like
in at least from a fan's perspective
they grossly mishandled you or just does
not did not know what to do with big
crit well the the the the building that
signed me
like i think two weeks a month later was
gone that happens a lot in the industry
you you you're already kind of starting
off rocky because you're not working
with the people that may have been
people who believed in you that brought
you in
they're gone and then man i was
determined and shout out to shot money
and my team i was determined to produce
my first album no matter what i was like
man there was a goal and it was
something that i needed to do for myself
because it was that idea old crit sign
why should [ __ ] change up so i just like
[ __ ] that you know and then i went
right into doing all the beats and
wanting to keep it the same way i did
with the mixtapes um and with the
projects at the time and so what
happened is the samples of some samples
i couldn't clear some features i
couldn't get then when you're mixing
that kind of stuff and you're having to
remove things off the whim it just
changed the narrative of what the album
originally would have felt like because
i i couldn't get sample clearances and
we fought for a lot of the records and i
had the i learned to change them [ __ ]
like three days before i had to turn
along with me and kind of stuff and i've
been listening to this live and
underground song a certain kind of way
and then it comes down to the whole
other way i got them i got to change it
i got to get this piano played but try
to make it sound old but you know what
it's like when you sample something then
you try to recreate it sometimes it's
not quite right but
in that album we show people that just
because you're not getting the label
support and they don't know what to do
with it doesn't mean that people aren't
gonna buy it it was a great album yeah
and me and my and my supporters came
through and then first week sales
[ __ ] looking at us like how did
y'all do that i was like i mean y'all
like i have they my people they come out
you know but even with singles trying to
get the single push and then [ __ ] we
dropped money on the floor in 2011
september my album didn't come out till
june 2012.
so i had to literally trying to promote
a single for damn near a year okay so
[ __ ] was here came out
when did return to forever drop 2011. it
came out march and then was the third
tape before the album
i had in foreign to keep the momentum
going i knew how long because forever in
a day you would already we're on def jam
right yeah i had to drop something in
order to keep the wow
you're like i mean
between you and wiz and i'm probably
forgetting but you guys had the albums
that weren't albums but they were albums
yeah i mean that was the best way to
keep people engaged it was free you know
because they weren't mixtapes they were
like this new thing where people were
just giving away real albums
that was the best that was your best
calling card at the time though yeah
like and then if you and then for me it
was like man i want to make sure that
this project competes with these major
label albums regardless of how i'm doing
it in my room we drop it randomly and
that's what it did to the point people
was like forever today should have been
your album
you know and i had to i had to i had to
take that with a grain of salt but i'm
like i spent a different kind of energy
it was different you didn't have to
worry about nobody even knows all the
red tape i just popped up and was like
yo
i remember forever in a day
or uh
the yeah your the last table for them
did drop out of nowhere yeah because i
told you i said we need to do something
it's like remember
there's a there's a print tape on two
dope boys
bro we need to drop this and then then
it becomes this thing where i had so
much creative
freedom to do it yeah so it i'm [ __ ]
working the cover the everything about
it just became oh that could have been
my album